le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
à la réunion lorsqu'un proche est malade
il doit parfois partir en métropole pour
réaliser des examens ou des opérations
spécifiques
c'est une partie du voyage est financé
par la sécurité sociale
de nombreux frais restent à la charge
des patients et de leurs accompagnants
c'est pourquoi le conseil départemental
a décidé d'aider les familles
réunionnaises dans ces moments
difficiles
de quelle façon c'est ce que nous allons
découvrir avec océane atteinte d'une
maladie génétique rare
la jeune fille a passé plusieurs
semaines dans un hôpital parisien avec
l'aide du conseil départemental
olivier son père a pu rester à ses côtés
pendant cette épreuve
[Musique]
nous sommes en 2015 océane à 13 ans elle
est en troisième
une année importante celle du brevet des
collèges contrairement à ses camarades
océane n'est pas en cours aujourd'hui
elle est à paris à l'hôpital raymond
poincaré où elle doit se faire opérer du
dos car elle souffre depuis tout petit
d'une scoliose conséquences de la
neurofibromatose maladie génétique rare
dont elle est atteinte manon reste pas
trop stressé exactement
trois fois la première fois la baie
saint paul et la g
si fait au pays là devant des multi ge
est là
le 26 mai par m c'est la troisième
opération pour océane qui va rester de
longues semaines à l'hôpital à dix mille
kilomètres de son île
un voyage pesant pour lequel la présence
de son père est indispensable mais pour
moi c'est mieux
ben ça m'aide mungo chemin j'en ai je
suis moins sales et avoir quelqu'un
qu'on connaît quelqu'un de proche
ben sahel pour le moral et ou en huile
comme d'habitude si oceana son père à
ses côtés
c'est notamment grâce à l'intervention
du département qui apporte un soutien
moral logistique et financier
indispensable
déjà ils vont récupérer l'aréoport nous
a emmenés directement à la maison
d'hébergement comme quoi non ce n'est
pas paris il faut prévoir le transport
ensuite nous ont donné un parc téléphone
appelé en janvier à lyon pour moi
externe et aussi avec un ticket le micro
mais trop con plus déplacée à l'hôpital
revenir parce que bon nous conte ici ne
peut pas vraiment tous les choses comme
à chacune de leurs visites
marilyn est présente
[Musique]
on avait des toits
marilyn est devenu bien plus qu'une
conseillère elle fait partie de la
famille sociale je vais rencontrer à
plusieurs reprises à chaque fois quand
on discute et je me disais je veux je
vous réussir je veux rentrer je veux
guérir
je vais avoir une vie normale et je vais
être considérée comme une enfant normale
juriste membre élevé la fin de l'année
on n'a plus qu'une envie c'est de l'idée
qu'on en fait
[Musique]
retour à la réunion après trois mois
passés à paris
elle est attendue avec impatience par le
reste de la famille aujourd'hui océane
est une adolescente elle a 16 ans elle
est déjà retourné en métropole
accompagné de son papa pour une
opération du visage océane et olivier
ont une fois de plus bénéficier des
aides du département et du soutien moral
de ses équipes de bon matin et elle est
là le département nous arrive
directement dans le pot donc c'est sympa
c'est plus un ponot donc sommes nous
arrivés à paris marc on sait par contre
choses donc on sait combien attendu par
une personne du département donc c'est
sûr qu'on se sent rassuré à chaque fois
c'est elle qui nous reçoit ben qui nous
accueillera elle peut voir un mètre sont
ans après la nuit cette ligue 1 depuis
la mise en place du dispositif en 2011
plus de 900 voyage de ce type ont été
prises en charge pour un budget de près
de deux cent mille euros dans quelques
mois
océane s'envolera de nouveau vers la
métropole pour une cinquième opération
elle continuera d'étudier pendant son
hospitalisation
car après avoir obtenu son brevet avec
mention elle a un nouvel objectif
obtenir le baccalauréat
[Musique]
vous devez accompagner un de vos proches
se faire soigner en métropole le
département peut vous aider à financer
votre billet d'avion votre hébergement
et votre restauration sur place
il vous offre également un pack
d'accueil avec un téléphone et des
tickets de transport pour bénéficier de
ce dispositif
les candidats doivent répondre à un
barème de ressources et sont choisis sur
dossier
selon leur situation sociale par le
conseil départemental
pour plus d'informations sur ce
dispositif un numéro vert est mis à
votre disposition au 0 800 800 812 147
vous pouvez aussi vous rendre sur le
site du conseil départemental au
www.cegedim.fr
[Musique]